cher journal j'ai décidé d'écrire un
film des années 50 un film de genre
enfin jean rainville quoi alors je sais
pas de quoi ça pourrait parler mais je
suis en train de faire la fiche et je me
disais qu'il me faudrait une comédienne
de la comédie française pour que ce soit
écrit machine de la comédie française au
générique
ça pourrait être l'histoire d'une flic
avec un lourd passé qui serait sur une
enquête qui ferait elle même écho à
cette histoire personnelle très
douloureuse
une femme blessée ne laisse rien
paraître de sa souffrance
une femme déterminée quoi intérieure ni
en sous sol un peu flippant le titre du
film de genre qui apparaît on aperçoit
la flic qui craque une allumette pour
allumer sa cigarette m'ont rappelé le
droit de fumer une cigarette
électronique
ah bah non c'est qu'on met dans les
années 50 bon bah la fumée qui sort de
sa bouche on dirait que il fait froid
voilà il a plu on devine le reflet de la
lune dans une flaque d'eau ah bah non
c'est con mais en sous sol j'ai dit bon
bah il ya un truc kafui un tuyau un truc
comme ça
un air de musique en mineur pour que ce
soit un petit peu dramatique se sont
toujours bien on pourrait être à new
york dans un film de scorsese
même si bon ou tournera très
probablement dans une banlieue française
sa coéquipière l'a rejoint une femme
humble mais très charismatique
incroyablement intelligente et surtout
d'une très très très grande beauté
[Musique]
ils ont l'air grave ils échangent un
regard qui en dit vraiment long tout en
garant dit vraiment non il est la
coéquipière lui fait oui de la tête
oui il est long ce phrasé typique des
vieux films en noir et blanc de quoi
j'écrirai les dialogues plus tard parce
que là j'ai pas trop le temps mais j'ai
le début la fin c'est cool je trouverai
bien qu'auteur pour le reste en tout cas
l'affiché bien je contente avec le jaune
là se fait bien genre film de genre bon
ben voila j'ai bien travaillé